quand les derniers bastions de daesh
sont tombés il y a quatre ans plus de 50
000 djihadistes et leurs familles ont
été envoyés dans ces camps de détention
au nord-est de la Syrie parmi eux plus
de 2000 familles étrangères beaucoup
d'enfants et des femmes de combattants
qui se disent d'innocentes
s'il y a un enfer sur terre je les
trouvais disait Kimberly polman à notre
collègue Marie-Ève Bédard en 2019 la
femme serait une des deux canadiennes
libéré tôt mardi matin du camp d'orge
avec deux enfants que confirme son
avocat
est dans un état lamentable dit-il je
suis certain que c'est en grande partie
à cause de cela qu'on veut la ramener au
pays Laurence greenspone représente dans
un recours collectif 23 Canadiens
toujours détenus en Syrie ils croient
que le Canada a les moyens de tous les
rapatrier
du Canada on parle de très peu de
personnes contrairement à d'autres pays
je pense entre autres à la France la
France a rapatrié la semaine dernière 55
ressortissants dont une quarantaine
d'enfants Amnesty internationale comme
d'autres organismes dénoncent l'approche
cas par cas du Canada depuis quatre ans
seulement deux enfants canadiens ont été
ramenés au pays on est particulièrement
préoccupé par rapport aux enfants qui
sont là mais évidemment on ne commande
pas sur des opérations une quarantaine
de Canadiens seraient encore devenu en
série dont 25 enfants je pense que ces
enfants vont être très sombre et seront
très paquets et donc ça aussi c'est un
autre c'est un autre enjeu parce que
plus ces personnes plus ces enfants
resteront longtemps dans ces camps-là
qui sont des endroits extrêmement
violents plus il risque d'être
radicalisé selon nos sources la deuxième
femme libérée ce matin reviendra à
Montréal dans les prochaines heures avec
ces deux enfants nés en Syrie elle
pourrait faire face à des accusations
criminelles ces personnes là ont droit à
la présomption d'innocence ont droit à
avoir un procès juste et équitable et le
col échéant aussi d'avoir une
condamnation qui soit juste et
proportionnelle au crime que ces
personnes ont commis c'est seulement
après un processus qui est géré par les
services policières indépendants
ottawa avait toujours refusé de
rapatrier des combattants djihadistes en
évoquant le risque qu'il représente pour
la sécurité des Canadiens aujourd'hui le
ministre dit qu'ils peuvent revenir
quand des enquêtes policières permettent
de faire la lumière sur de possibles
crimes commis en Syrie ici Sophie
Langlois Radio-Canada Montréal